[Music]
That's right,
my chestnuts are good.
Dqn The richness of sugar butter is concentrated.
It
's the main butter improvement created by Toshiaki Saito, who has a lineup of top-notch materials. I'll cut
off the car and the snow drool to the
fullest
.
The body doesn't come in Japan
[Music]
ni
Church Best Dinosaur Figure management Good at pouring Juice that is
nicely baked The
sugar contained in a small amount on this day reacts with butter and has a wonderful fragrance  The perfect
buttery squid liver has a butter mirror with a sunshade and a pleasant bitterness.
There is also a serious secret in vinegared rice that it is used abundantly but the taste is not bad. It is
a special vinegared rice made from yuzu juice and lemon juice.
Just adding butter, which is a lump of fat, to plenty of seafood will naturally make you persistent.
To create a light flavor that does not make you feel it,
I used orange to enhance the freshness.
There are many things that match the range of
butter bar It is the best effect to color the strong butter scent if you keep an eye on it to make the best use of the turn.
It
’s the appearance of a samurai who fights with the soul of the past.